Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan.
Today starts the first video
in my course, the complete guide to Kubescape.
This video is made possible by the amazing
team at ARMOR
who kindly sponsored my time so that I
could make this course for you.
So, what is Kubescape?
Kubescape
scans Kubernetes clusters, YAML files and Helm charts,
detecting misconfiguration
according to multiple frameworks.
Frameworks such as SIS,
NSA SISA, and MITRE ATT CK, and a
few more.
As well as misconfigurations,
it scans for software vulnerabilities
and RBAC role based access control violations.
You can do this at early stages of
your build pipeline,
as early as on your machine as you're
writing your code,
perhaps in CICD.
And today, I'll be taking a look at
running Kubescape and your cluster for continuous scanning
of misconfigurations
and vulnerabilities.
Now the answer isn't to pick one or
the other, but possibly all of the above.
Because Kubescape calculates a risk score instantly and
shows you trends over time.
The more you scan, the more benefits you're
going to get.
I've had a lot of fun experimenting with
Kubescape this past week,
and today's video will show you how to
get started,
continuously scan your Kubernetes cluster and cluster with
the Kubescape operator,
and use Kubescape Cloud to visualize and consume
that information.
Let's dive in.
Okay.
So how did we set up this cluster?
All this code is available online at github.com
slash Rawkode Academy.
There you will find a repository called the
Kubescape complete guide.
This gives you some Pulumi automation to spin
up a brand new cluster on AKS, EKS,
and JKE.
You can see here, I've got simple helper
functions to create each of these clusters.
Feel free to do this once for any
part of the Kubescape course that we're gonna
be working through today and subsequent days.
Feel free to reuse this automation if it
makes sense for you.
Now because we are going to use Kubescape
and cluster and Kubescape Cloud, we do need
to provide our account ID.
You can get this by logging in to
Kubescape Cloud and go to your settings page.
I'm storing this in a Pulumi secret value
so that it can be consumed and injected
into my Kubernetes clusters when I run Pulumi
app.
There's just a little bit of glue needed
to configure the provider to configure the providers
in a format that we need to do
multiplexing.
That is using Pulumi to deploy a single
resource to multiple clusters.
From here, we can look over each of
our providers
and I'm deploying Flux two,
Grafana,
and then Kubescape.
Why am I deploying Flux and Grafana?
Well, we just wanna see a few extra
data points as we scan our cluster for
Kubescape.
Kubescape provide a wonderful helm chart that allows
us to deploy their cloud operator.
You can find that at kubescape.github.i0/helm-charts.
The chart
is very easy to configure and that all
I really need to provide is my account
ID and the name of my cluster.
For my cluster name, that is AKS,
EKS,
and JKE.
Nice and simple.
When I run a Pulumi app, I'll have
three clusters all with Kubescape installed and I
can go straight to this and
I can go straight to Kubescape Cloud.
So let's take a look
at the Kubescape Cloud dashboard.
On this homepage, you'll see the three clusters
that I spun up in preparation.
AKS, EKS, GKE. Promise is the last time
I'm gonna say that.
We have two tables,
one for configuration risk and one for vulnerability
risk.
Configuration risk is going to show you
all the opportunities that you have to fix
your Kubernetes manifests
and helm charts to represent
what the industry considers best practice.
This comes from a bunch of different frameworks.
Like NSE, MITRE, DevOps best, SIS, ARMOR best
and all controls.
If we wanna take a look at the
SIS framework and see which controls fail, we
get so. If we want to look at
MITRE,
NSA,
and so forth.
If we want to look at all controls,
and
what this is changing as the violations
are control failures over time.
You can see here that when I first
deployed Kubescape to these clusters,
these violations across these clusters, can see JKE,
ETS here.
We move across and then the numbers change
and then the numbers cross and they change
again.
And theory, the longer that you have Kubescape
deployed
and the more that you're deploying to the
cluster, you know, we're we live in an
age of Kubernetes and micro It's not uncommon
for clusters
to have hundreds, maybe thousands, maybe even tens
of thousands of workloads on them. And those
workloads because the micro services evolve and deploy
quite fast. It's not uncommon to have tens
of thousands of deployments per day.
As those manifest change
as you're evolving them, maybe they're shared. Maybe
you have a common base that you use
to deploy all your web apps. And I
changed there. It could actually have a huge
cascading
failure
alert or at least failed controls.
And when they propagate down the stack.
So you can use this little table as
a way to see if you've got any
major incidents where you see a peak and
then a trough, which could be a break
and a fix of those manifests across your
cluster.
My table looks a bit weak and a
bit bland and that's just because these clusters
are not old and the agent itself hasn't
been running on it very long. However, there
are a few changes that we could see
over time.
On the right hand side, we have the
field controls and the color of the bar
indicates the cluster, which has the violation of
the field controls
and then the length of the bar as
the number of times this has been had
across your workloads.
And if we click on one,
we get taken to the cubescape documentation.
This is fantastic.
This tells me the ID number so here
we're looking at C50,
which is receipt, which
is receipt, which is resource CPU and limit
request.
The workloads in my cluster don't have this
by default, not all of them at least.
So we get which framework
that's real applies to us. So DevOps best
practice all controls in the animal scan. The
severity of this is high. Obviously, if we
don't special, if we don't specify
resource limits
and request for CPU memory,
Then our applications won't schedule properly, they could
potentially consume more memory than we want them
to
and saturate that for other workloads on the
cluster.
We get a description telling us why this
control is important.
We also get related resources. These are the
resources that this control can be detected on.
So cron job daemon set deployment pod jobs
replica set and stable sets of course.
And then we have a remediation path.
If you want to get rid of this
field control, set a CPU limit or use
exception mechanism to avoid unnecessary notifications.
And then we have the configuration that we
can change on those resources to make this
field control
a
successful control past control. I'm not sure, not
a failed control, at least.
Let's pick up one more. This is from
a different cluster.
We have C0034
automatic mapping of a service account.
This is our best MSA all controls in
the animal scan with a medium severity.
Now,
all my clusters run on the default for
the cloud provider. So AKS and EKS and
JKE all run. I said that was the
last thing I was gonna say. All run
one twenty three by default. So these are
one twenty three clusters, which means
they're not one twenty five clusters Kubernetes one
twenty five is when the automatic mounting of
a service account was disabled.
So in any cluster older than that, when
you don't realize it, all your pods have
credentials to speak to the Kubernetes API server,
but some level of permissions.
And this is not something that you really
want all of your workloads to be able
to do. Why should NGINX be speaking to
my Kubernetes API server.
So we have to release the resources, this
is everything that can run a pod essentially
tells you about the control test and then
the remediation as to this to disable
the automatic mounting, and it gives you an
example of what that looks like. So we
set automatic service account token to falls on
our service account. You can even do this
on a workload at self.
So you have a couple of options.
So this first configuration table is really great.
We see those sales controls over time. We
can monitor for events with cascading failures.
And we have the ability to just get
a quick view of the top five field
control, the top five field controls so that
we can start to reduce that number
with the controls that are potentially easiest to
fix.
The second table is a vulnerability risk.
This is now moving beyond misconfiguration
and actually scanning the images that our application
drawn on within our cluster.
This is scanning for known CVEs.
CVEs are plentiful and bountiful
And they just keep on coming. As you
can see here across our workloads, we've got
36 critical 165
high 190 medium 36 low, a whole bunch
of negligible and some unknowns.
So, this could be very difficult to prioritize
an action. See this time and time again
as a work with organizations.
Some of them have taken steps to do
some scanning, but the remediation factor is difficult
because
there are just so many of them by
default and some of these base images. If
you're using base have been to base
Red Hat or Santos, etcetera.
CVEs are there, they can fast and unfortunately
the base layers aren't being built quick enough
to maintain or keep up with the changes.
Now,
we can use the critical and high as
a benchmark to say we probably want to
fix these, but doesn't mean you can neglect
the mediums will those negligible and unknown. They
still require some manual scanning someone to review
and understand.
Can be fixed those.
Could be the 90 mediums are actually relatively
easy left and you can wipe them off
the face of the air for one change.
Unlikely but potential and plausible.
Now even at the critical and high, we're
still close to 200
field controls.
So,
like we can with a configuration one, we
can see the change over time and we
have the top CVEs on the right. What
I love about this table is it has
55 WL.
This is showing us that 55 workloads are
affected by the CVE.
Now, we can drill in on this by
clicking on it, and we'll be able to
see the workloads that this affects. Obviously we've
got 55 so it's quite a lot.
And,
But we can see that flux is affected.
Grafana
flux flux flux
ECR stuff.
CubeScape itself.
Microsoft.
So this is a very broad spectrum CVE
that affects a lot of base images. It
could be they'll rely on the same base
layer and they all need updated. It's hard
to tell. However,
what we can do is filter on the
top here.
One, we can turn on this flag which
tells us which of these have remote code
execution.
These are the ones that we probably want
to try and fix first even if they're
medium,
even if a low, even though a low
RCE probably wouldn't be low because these are
the ones that allow
somebody potentially to run commands within our cluster.
Now you might be thinking, well, my pods
are publicly available that these images are on.
However, remember lateral movement within a cluster as
an attack vector that you need to be
very careful with. So even if you feel
that your workload isn't available on the public
Internet, if you have any, any workload available
on the public Internet
lateral movement is there. Be cautious.
However, we can see that we can fix
or there are six criticals to have an
RCE 11 high.
Those are the ones I probably want to
prioritize first.
However, there's one more toggle on the screen.
And it's as there are effects available.
That's as your low hanging fruit.
The golden path here is that the ones
with RCEs have effects available and we can
knock them out together.
And what we see is that of the
criticals we have 19 that have effects we
have 44 that have effects on high and
78 mediums with effects.
So we're able to drastically reduce these numbers
as long as we know which workloads and
how to apply the fact.
And that's why scrolling down now becomes even
more important.
What we can do here is take a
look at this path here.
So, on
this GKE image,
10 criticals, eight fixes, 20 highs, 11 fixes,
15 mediums, eight fixes, and then the lows.
So let's click on this.
And from here, we'll see the image scanner
report for this net D image from GKE.
We can scroll down to the bottom and
it now shows us the individual CVEs that
have the fixes available.
We can see that the first CVE twenty
one three nine nine nine was in libc
dash bin.
We can see here that it's a high
severity fix available and the upgrade path is
to change from 23113
dev 11 u three to u four.
And in fact, all the fixes here
are a small update to the debian package.
So, while I can't
change the net DGK image myself.
Let's assume this is my own workload and
the cluster.
And right now, in fact it's very common
for organizations to all share a common base
layer, if they're using a base layer and
not something this release or scratch, etc. But
if you are using Alpine or Ubuntu or
Santos as that base, it may be quite
common for these same
issues
and failed controls and the vulnerability scan to
be quite common and persistent across all of
your images and it could be that rebuilding
that base layer is a very, not easy,
but maybe trivial way to roll out that
fix fast across your entire fleet.
So what Kubescape is doing from this dashboard
view
with the both the tables for configuration vulnerabilities,
given me a way to identify
the issues that deserve my attention.
By using the top links on the right,
we can drill that down to the ones
that have the most bang for buck or
the ones that affect the most workloads.
From there, we can identify the images that
we need to be looking at and hopefully
using this the nice toggles with RCEs and
have fix these, we can identify the ones
that deserve our attention first.
From there, we can plan out our remediation
path as a platform team or SRE team
and roll out those fixes across our fleet.
And that all took less than ten minutes.
So I'm really impressed with Kubescape Cloud so
far.
The fact that I was able to find
a dashboard, analyze my infrastructure,
find RCEs,
have fixes,
work out some sort of remediation path in
my head very very quickly it's a testament
to how good the UI is delivering
what is a vast amount of information and
a very considerable way.
The Kubescape team.
Thumbs up. Great work.
So we drilled down a little bit there,
going from the top CVEs into image scanning.
But let's take a look at the config
scanning.
From here, we get an overview of all
of our clusters and the frameworks that we
choose to pay attention to. I have specifically
configured each of my clusters
to give me the most information or at
the most upfront information about NSE,
MITRE, and SIS.
I can click on any cluster and change
that. We have the ability to select free.
So I can see turn off my turn
and let's turn on our best.
Now when I come back here, I have
NSE that's a normal best.
And I can do this in a mall,
whether I want them all to be the
same or I want them all to be
different. It's up to you. I found that
quite, that it works quite well
to have some all the same to give
me a same pane of glass to all
my clusters.
And in fact, what we can see here
with the default managed Kubernetes experience across the
three major clouds, I won't say their name
again,
is that AKS has
three NSE field controls,
nine sys field controls and three Arnold best
practice fields controls.
The Amazon one has two NSA, 10 sys
and two ARMOR.
And the Googly one has six NSA, 17
sys and five ARMOR.
So that default out of the box experience
is different across all of the clusters.
Now I don't know if that should make
any
if that should have any importance in your
decision making. I know I'm more likely still
to go for the Google one when required.
But as security conscious decisions are one that
you have to make, that may provide a
good framework for helping make that decision.
When we click on a cluster,
we get to see the score over time
again.
But not only that we can have a
nice big list of the tables of all
of those fields controls.
We can sort them by whatever is important
to us.
So maybe we want to tackle all the
critical past first,
or perhaps we just want to
see which ones have the most failures. So
it could be here.
We have the automatic mapping of a service
account into 18 or we have 18 failures
of this check across this
Microsoft cluster.
So, we can click on this, and we'll
see all the resources that this fails on.
We can see that cert manager has a
job and a service account with these properties.
We can see in our default namespace, we've
got all the flux controllers.
And we can actually add exceptions if we
want to.
So say we've made the decision that hey,
flux is gonna be flux.
And we don't mind that has that token.
We just turn on the default namespace or
the flux system namespace depends on how you
have it deployed.
Or maybe it's a cert manager, we're gonna
let cert manager cert manager. So we're going
to apply an exemption for all of that.
We have the ability to pick and choose,
but it could be that we actually want
to remediate.
So we can click on the fix
and it'll take us to the YAML and
it shows us the line
that we need to add to our cluster.
Now I'm not going to download this YAML
or copy this object. However,
this is a very simple
field control.
Not all of them are going to be
fixed by one line of YAML.
For those more complicated cases where it might
need four or five ten twenty who knows,
lines of YAML.
This view is going to be really good
and that we can copy and download it
if we want. Can apply a depth to
existing resource and get the change that we
need. Although to be honest, that's as doing
a defecation to existing resource.
So you could probably just copy and paste
the lines that are green and off you
go.
Tells you which lines are different and we
have the ability to share this with people
if we want.
We're going to move on. So it's really
good having this insights and to the configuration
changes across my cluster. We can also initiate
a new scan for our cluster if we
want by clicking the scan button. We can
tell the frameworks that we wish to scan
for this time. And as you'll see I
actually have a scheduled scan for 8AM
every single day running all frameworks.
So a lot of flexibility and power into
the way that you interact with the scanning
within your cluster. Cluster.
And this is because of the way that
we are deploying Kubescape and cluster rather than
running it as a local process.
Now don't worry if you do want to
run Kubescape as a local CLI. I'm going
to be covering that next along with CICD
integration in my next video. So stay tuned.
One last thing I'd like to cover as
part of the configuration scanning is that we're
looking at it as the lens of which
controls have failed.
However,
it's also very useful to take a look
at which resources
have violations or failed controls.
Now we can sort by the kind, which
may not be terribly useful.
And if I see a conflict map of
a failed control that would be madly amusing.
We may wish to sort by which resources
have the most field controls.
And as we can see here, it's my
cert manager, which has nine field controls.
I can click on the field controls, and
I can see we've
got no memory limits. We've got no CPU
limits, no resource limits ingress and egress blocked
or not blocked, I guess, automatic service account
mapping. We have images from any registry we're
not restricting that within a low list. There's
no probes, and it does not have an
immutable container file system.
Now knowing how certain other works maybe we
know that it's never going to have an
immutable file system. So let's exempt it. And
maybe it doesn't have a way to do
a resonance probe so we'll exempt that too.
And we click close.
If we want to get more information on
the fix we click this banner.
And now you can see we've got changes
at lane 55,
which is to add limits and requests for
memory.
And the next one.
Oh, we can add the read only file
system.
Line 61.
We can add a readiness probe.
We can turn off the automatic of the
service account.
So, this ability to see how to make
changes to existing resources on a way to
fix the fields control I think is an
invaluable tool.
So let's jump back.
We've taken a look at how to identify
misconfigurations
from the lens of the controls that are
failing with us get to prioritize
the controls that are important to us,
or potentially the controls that we know we
can fix quickly.
We also have the ability to find the
workloads within our cluster that are failing the
most. So maybe we can identify ways to
get them up to scratch or exempt them
as the workloads out with our control. And
a managed Kubernetes cluster, you cannot modify a
lot of the workload running on the cube
system namespace.
So you're just gonna have to rely on
the managed provider
to do their job.
So exempt them if you can and if
you must.
Alright. We have one more feature that I
wanna cover on Kubescape Cloud and that is
the RBAC Visualizer.
Understanding
the scope and breadth of role based access
control within your Kubernetes cluster is a hell
of a challenge.
So many service accounts, something called groups, who
knows what those are.
Roles,
cluster roles, cluster role bindings, role bindings.
The things that you need to know to
understand who can do what within your cluster
requires a lot of access to Kubescape control
on the command line.
And maybe you're using Kubescape control off, can
I? But there is an easier way.
Enter the RBAC
visualizer.
From here, we can see it. Let's take
a look at one of our clusters.
I'll start off by selecting the Amazon one.
Now we get this overview of all the
service accounts, groups, roles
and the verbs
that they can act on the resources they
can act upon.
Now by default you get this kind of
broken down look
and you can see here in this box
we have the default namespace.
In fact, if I zoom in,
you'll see NS default.
And this, as we've seen from previous parts
of Kubescape is where I'm running my flux
CD deployment.
If we pop over here, we have another
box and this time it's our Kubescape box.
This is our Kubescape namespace.
We'll see the workloads, the service accounts and
the roles that they have access to and
the resources
that I can act upon.
So we get this lovely visual
description
or way to interact and describe I guess
a map
of
all the important RBAC stuff within our cluster.
Now what's cool is that we have the
ability to tweak the way this is laid
out. So first we can say it less
group by verb. Now at this kind of
overview, that's not gonna do a lot. So
we'll just turn that off.
What we'll do a lot is layout by
type.
Now we can have a kind of top
down map of the workloads within our cluster,
the service accounts that they consume
and we have the roles
that those service accounts have.
We see
that this CRD controller role
is used by all of the service accounts
for all of the flux CD components
And actually flux being that it is a
get up to operator and a Kubernetes cluster
with super special privileges
can star
on all resources.
It's all stars all the time.
In our cluster. Oh, that's as we expect.
So not really worth calling out.
Let's take a look at something else. What
about Kubescape itself?
Well, we have our Kubescape
workloads.
We got the staple set deployment, some more
deployments. We've got the service accounts that they
use. So we've got the Kubescape,
Kubescape SA and the KSSC.
This uses the KSSC rules, which has the
ability to star
on cron jobs.
And we've got the ability to star on
config maps.
Over on the other side, we've got this
service account, which is the SA rules or
Kubescape SA rules which has star on namespaces
and star on demon sets.
So as you can see, my cluster and
this default managed configuration with just a couple
of workloads doesn't really have a lot of
interest in our back history.
But it doesn't mean that we can't get
some useful insights anyway.
We have this who can drop down. So
what if we want to know who can
create
pods?
We click the who can confirm,
It shows us the pods could be created
by all of these rules. We can see
some system controller rules which is as we
would expect especially for the replica set controller.
And we have the daemon set controller too.
So the only thing that can create pods
are the controllers which should actually be able
to create pods.
This is good. This is exactly what we
wanted to see.
So let's clear the who can
and clear
pods.
We also have this query drop down. This
query drop down shows you common queries that
are useful for understanding
common queries that people may want to ask
of the R back within our cluster.
One that I often like to ask is
who can exec into a pod.
And if we scroll down here, we'll see
a query
show who can exec into pods.
And when we run this, we see that
cluster admin can, which of course you can,
Cluster admin is the cluster admin role within
the cluster.
But also the CRD controller.
So our flux deployment actually gives
a bunch of its controllers, the source controller,
the notification controller, the image controller,
the image automation controller and the helm controller
and the customized controller, the ability to execute
commands within parts.
Again,
given the way the flux works, we'll probably
write this off as being okay.
But if you've any other workloads in there
to have the ability to exec executes
commands within a pod.
That's something that you would want to identify.
Another common query could be, do I have
any rules my cluster that are not being
used, Maybe I can actually clean some of
this stuff up. Well, we can say show
unassigned rules.
These are all system rules, so not things
we really need to worry about, but again,
any more production like cluster and we'll do
some work on one of my real clusters
and a common video soon.
We can actually identify when maybe we've had
workloads that created roles and we've removed them,
but the roles have been left around.
Those lying around in your cluster are potential
attack vectors for other peep for people that
have access to your Kubernetes API.
So it's generally best to clean them up.
The last feature I'll show up in our
back visualizer
is the investigate button. This is when you
want to work out how one individual resource
or a few resources
work or collaborate with other things in the
system.
So I'm going to start by clicking clear
and then I'm going to click investigate.
From here, I get a list of of
subjects, roles, resources, workloads, role by the verbs
and API groups.
Now it could be that I want to
understand the Flux CD API group.
I can do customize,
source,
helm, notifications,
and image.
Not only that, I'm curious about a workload.
Maybe I want to understand how the helm
controller functions.
From here, we can see
the CRD controller role
and the resources it can act upon because
of the filter
on the API group.
We can see the deployment helm controller
because I added it as part of the
workload selector.
We can now explore just these resources with
the deployment helm deployment controller. I can right
click and say, well, show me your service
accounts.
And we can see the service account here.
I could also right click and say show
related resources.
And now it pulls in
both the roles that it has access to
and all the resources
that it can work,
that it can act upon.
So now I have a pretty good understanding
of the permission model for the helm controller
and just a few clicks.
So that's been today's video.
Taking a look at Kubescape Cloud by running
Kubescape in my clusters
across all three major cloud providers with a
couple of default workloads.
I've been playing with Kubescape and Kubescape Cloud
for the last week and I've gotta say
I'm really impressed.
You get a lot of bang for buck
with just a simple Helm deployed to the
cluster passing on one simple value. From there,
I'm able to understand misconfiguration,
vulnerabilities
and RBAC.
These are three things that are notoriously and
infamously hard to understand within the Kubernetes context.
It's a lot of information that needs visual
paradigms to be able to get fast understanding.
So I hope you find this video useful.
Go check out Kubescape Cloud and Kubescape.
We'll be back in a few days with
another video looking at Kubescape CLI and how
we integrate that into CICD pipelines.
Until next time, I'll see you soon.